صوتك
الان احنا اصحاب القضيه
[موسيقى]
اما النصر او اسقاط النظام بكامل اركانه
هذا نظام مجرم ارهابي لا مجال للتعايش معه
باي شكل من الاشكال فلكل شخص سياسي يحسب
نفسه على الثوره السوريه اما انت تعمل ضمن
مظله الثوره السوريه او اما عليك بالرحيل
لا مجال لتعويم الاسد ايا كان الظروف
[موسيقى]
صالح اللاعب
السوري
عبد الرحمن مصطفى وقال بان المصالحه مع
نظام الاسد هي الحل السياسي الامثل السوري
اليوم لكي اسقطهم هذه الاجسام التي جلبت
الويلات السوريين على كافه المناحي
[موسيقى]
اليوم النظام هو عمال بترنح ما عندي طعم
الشعب الي موجود عنده
نحن اليوم بدنا نوقفهم صالح معه فشار هو
باذن الله عز وجل هو وده صالحه على سطح
الارض كلياتنا نحن ما لنا وجود وقت يصير
هذا الامر
انا لله
العظيم استمرتي ثورتنا
في الحريه والكرامه
واسقاط النظام المجرم
نحن ثوابتنا بالثوره الموت ولا المذله
ونحن طلعنا ضد هذا النظام من البدايه
للنهايه لاسقاط نظام بشار الاسد